je vous apporte la nouvelle tous les
loups tous les agneaux plus jamais le se
querelle auumain ruiseau je vous apporte
la nouvelle les lapins et les mulau sont
amis avec les aigles et s'envolent sur
leur dos les savants les plus habiles
réunis dans une tour ont déclaré
maintenant qu'il est temps de soigner le
mal d'amour plus de peur plus de menac
de vaincu ou de vainqueurs les canons
sont à la
on en fera des tracteurs les canons sont
à la C on en fera des
tracteurs je vous apporte la nouvelle
tous les lou tous les agneau plus
jamais mê ru je vous apporte la nouvelle
les seigneurs et les baniers ont ouvert
le citad à la vraie communauté un
martien sur notre terre de vivre ici
Satan est plus en enfer il paraît qu'il
préfère le paradis les journaux sont
pleins de choses merveilleuses à
raconter les colombes se reposent elles
l'avait bien mérité les colombes se
reposent elle l'avait bien
mériter je vous apporte la nouvelle tous
les loups tous les agneaux plus jamais
de ce querelle au bord du même ruiseau
je vous apporte la nouvelle les
princesses les rois ce mari et son
fidèle on nait jamais vu ça et je me
suis réveillé en sursut tout habillé et
tout le monde av r à la table où je
metis en dormis voilà ce qu'on a rêvé
bien sûr ça n'existe pas et pourtant
nous voulons croire que ça nous arrivera
nous apportons la nouvelle tous les l
tous les agneaux plus jamais ne se
querelle bumme ruissau mon bum Mme
ruissau mon bumme
[Applaudissements]
ruissau